[Música]
chile comenzó a registrar a los
migrantes en el país las autoridades
explican que esto no es un procedimiento
para normalizar la condición irregular
en la que se encuentran sino para
aumentar la seguridad Quienes no Se
acojan podrían ser expulsados más
fácilmente
se cumplieron dos años de las históricas
manifestaciones anti gubernamentales en
Cuba el 11 de julio de 2021 miles de
cubanos salieron a las calles para
protestar por la crisis económica y para
pedir libertad el gobierno reprimió a
los manifestantes y cientos permanecen
encarcelados al día de hoy
Honduras sigue luchando contra la
violencia en las prisiones durante un
nuevo operativo policial en cárceles del
país fueron incautadas cientos de armas
y municiones además en la denominada
operación fe y Esperanza trasladaron más
de 1600 pesos de alta peligrosidad a dos
cárceles de máxima seguridad
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Franz 24 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias de
América soy Santiago ariztía Y empezamos
en Chile el país comenzó el registro
biométrico para más de 190.000 migrantes
este proceso hace parte de la nueva
política migratoria del gobierno de
Gabriel borich con la que espera
controlar los ingresos así como también
la permanencia de los extranjeros y
agilizar eventuales expulsiones las
autoridades señalan que es una medida
que mejorará las condiciones de
seguridad de la nación Sudamericana hubo
caro nos cuenta más
chile toma medidas para el control de la
migración irregular una nueva política
pretende registrar a más de 190.000
extranjeros en el país se hará mediante
un sistema biométrico que permitirá
controlar las entradas permanencia y
agilizar las expulsiones inicia lo que
hemos denominado el empadronamiento
biométrico de personas migrantes que han
ingresado de manera irregular a Chile
Esto va a permitir en primer lugar
entregar mejores condiciones de
seguridad al país en los últimos años
chile experimentó un incremento en el
flujo de migrantes dentro de su
territorio sus fronteras con Perú y
Bolivia son algunas de las vías de
acceso más importantes para los
extranjeros que buscan entrar al país
para el proceso estarán abiertas más de
70 comisarías de la policía civil y será
aplicable a mayores de 18 años quienes
darán información como nombres apellidos
huellas dactilares fotografías y sus
antecedentes un procedimiento la cual
nos ayuda mucho migrante porque no
solamente por nacionalidad
y
es como un procedimiento en la cual no
es regularización pero igual tiene un
control migratorio que hace falta sobre
todo más acá en Chile a pesar de que
esta política favorecería a los
migrantes en temas como el acceso
laboral la medida retira la notificación
previa en Casos de expulsión a los
migrantes con antecedentes con esto
chile apunta a la seguridad y el control
y se cumplieron dos años de las inéditas
e históricas protestas en Cuba por la
crítica situación económica y a favor de
la libertad que recordemos que fueron
duramente reprimidas las autoridades
cubanas sentenciaron a cientos de
personas por cargos que van desde
desorden público hasta la sedición lo
que provocó denuncias por violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos el gobierno de La
Isla responsabiliza Estados Unidos por
las movilizaciones en 24 en español
dialogamos con darse y borrero ella es
integrante del colectivo justicia oncej
hablamos acerca de las detenciones a a
partir de aquellas protestas esto nos
decía en este caso nuestra organización
surgió
la desesperación nos llevó como
ciudadanas a documentar los casos en ese
momento eran desapariciones forzadas de
corto término porque no sabíamos no
conocíamos el paradero de las personas
que que habían manifestada que se habían
manifestado en Cuba a lo largo de 60
localidades del país entonces esa lista
empezó a crecer y a crecer hasta el día
de hoy que manejamos un total de mil
ochocientas sesenta detenciones a
personas que se manifestaron en el país
y bueno en la actualidad las cifras
también han variado en cuanto a los que
permanecen detenidos esta cifra quedaba
inicialmente se refiere a detenciones
desde el 11 de Julio hasta la actualidad
no quiere decir que todas esas personas
las 1860 estén detenidas al día de hoy
sino que hoy por hoy las que
contabilizamos son más de 700 en prisión
el régimen de hecho dio
información de que 790 personas estaban
siendo procesadas en el país en relación
con el estallido del once j y bueno
posteriormente nosotros alcanzamos Esa
esa cifra y la superamos también una una
cifra que nos guste Resaltar Porque es
importante decirlo es que al casi 100
personas casi sin centenar de personas
han tenido que exiliarse como resultado
de estas protestas masivas de CJ
avanzamos con más noticias que llegan
desde Cuba el gobierno de La Isla
denunció Este martes que Estados Unidos
trasladó hasta la Bahía de guantánamo un
submarino de propulsión nuclear
Washington respondió que tiene el
derecho de desplazar activos a su base
militar de guantánamo y el departamento
de estado destacó que seguirán volando
navegando y trasladando los hasta donde
lo permite al derecho internacional por
su parte el canciller cubano Bruno
Rodríguez calificó este hecho como una
escalada provocadora
la presencia allí de un submarino
nuclear en estos momentos obliga a
cuestionar Cuál es la razón militar del
hecho en esta región pacífica del mundo
contra qué objetivo se dirige Y qué
propósito estratégico persigue debe
recordarse que las 33 naciones de la
región son firmantes de la declaración
de América Latina y el Caribe como zona
de paz suscrita en la Habana en enero de
y noticias de México los manifestantes
de Chilpancingo la capital del Estado de
Guerrero liberaron a los 13 agentes
militares y empleados públicos que
tenían retenidos desde el lunes la
ciudad ha estado sitiada desde la semana
pasada tras la captura de dos personas
que transportaban droga y armas el
gobierno Estatal responsabiliza al grupo
criminal los ardillos de estar detrás de
las protestas para mantener su negocios
de Amapola y tráfico de goma de opio en
la tarde de este martes líderes de las
manifestaciones se reunieron con las
autoridades locales y pactaron liberar a
los 13 retenidos
y durante un operativo policial en las
cárceles de Honduras fueron incautadas
cientos de armas y municiones entre
estos artículos se hallan rifles
automáticos pistolas cuchillos granadas
de fragmentación drogas joya dinero en
efectivo y también dispositivos de
comunicación durante la rueda de prensa
de las autoridades Estas armas fueron
incineradas y cortadas en la denominada
operación fe y Esperanza trasladaron a
más de 1.600 presos de alta peligrosidad
a dos cárceles de máxima seguridad Estas
armas no ingresaron por sí solas todo lo
que ustedes miran ahí obligatoriamente
tuvieron que haber tenido una
complicidad
de las personas que la misión era
proteger la misión era evitar que estos
pues armas drogas dinero ingresarán a
estos centros penales avanzamos con más
noticias una de las integrantes de la
secta conocida como la familia Mason
salió de prisión de que una prisión de
California tras 53 años habiendo estado
recluida Leslie fue puesta en Libertad
condicional bajo supervisión el
gobernador del estado el demócrata gavin
se mostró decepcionado con la decisión
que tomó el tribunal de apelación Aunque
dijo que no recurrirá la medida más
auten había sido condenada a cadena
perpetua por su participación en dos
asesinatos cometidos un día antes de que
miembros de la familia Mason mataran a
la actriz Sharon tate esposa del
director de cine Roman Polanski en un
ataque del cual bauten no participó
y un documento escrito a mano por la
cantante a rizar Franklin y encontrado
en su sofá después de su muerte en el
año 2018 es un testamento válido en
Michigan Esto es lo que afirmó un Jurado
Este martes y de esta manera se da un
giro en la disputa que ha enfrentado a
los hijos del artista es una victoria
para que Edward Franklin en cuyos
abogados habían argumentado que los
documentos fechados en 2014 deberían
anular un testamento de 2010 que fue
descubierto casi al mismo tiempo en un
gabinete cerrado con llave en la casa de
La Reina del Sol en Detroit ambos se
habían Unido contra el hermano
a quien favorecía El testamento del año
[Música]
y para finalizar deportes en france24 en
español y es que el Astro del fútbol
Lionel Messi llegó a Estados Unidos el
martes antes de su presentación como
jugador del inter Miami el club prepara
un evento especial para la presentación
del 7 veces ganador del Balón de Oro el
domingo en una entrevista para la
televisión pública de Argentina Messi
aseguró de estar contento con la
decisión y con muchas ganas de enfrentar
el nuevo desafío
de esta manera llegamos al final de esta
emisión informativa Recuerden que pueden
ampliar estas noticias y conocer
muchísimas más en Franz 24.com Gracias
por acompañarnos y sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]